كواليس اعلان الموسم بين رونالدو وميسي
والرسائل المبطنه وتويتر في وسط عاصفه
شديده ولكن ماسك اخر روقان وجالسين نركز
وحقيقه الفيديو المتداول لصفحه الرئيس
الفرنسي ماكرون اهلا بكم
قبل ايام من انطلاق كاس العالم في صوره
انتشرت على من الصوت وفعليا فجرت الانترنت
حول العالم وفي الغالب كلكم
مسيو رونالدو في صوره واحده او اعلان واحد
صوره ناس كثير للوحله الاولى اصلا شكت في
حقيقتها وقالت انه مفبركه وانه يعني اكبر
متنافسين في العالم كره القدم بيطلعوا سوا
اعلان واحد مو معقول لكن الصوره اتضح انها
صحيحه لو انها فعلا اعلان مركز الشهيره
ويعني مجرد ظهور الاثنين في الاعلان سواء
خلاك صار يعتبروا هذا الاعلان اعلان
الموسم لكن تفاصيل اضافيه بدات تتضح شويه
شويه واثبت انه الاعلان فعليا تاريخي
الصوره مثل ما شفته بيظهر فيها رونالدو
وميسي وهم ابو شطرنج علشان شنطه الوي فيتو
وبيلعبوا من غير لوح شطرنج لانهم
بيستخدموا مربعات الشنطه اللي هو احد
التصاميم المعروفه للملكه او للماركه
كبديل لوحه الشطرنج فكره انهم بيلعبوا
مباراه ضد بعض فيها نوع من الرساله عن
التنافس الشديد بينهم خاصه وانه يعني اكثر
لاعبين في كره القدم في انقسام حولهم مين
الافضل فيهم ميسي ولا رونالدو يعني في
معسكر خلف هذا ومعسكرات ثانيه خلف هذا
الناس تقول ميسي
تقول لا رونالدو
طيب كره التنافس بينهم على مين الافضل
يعني ملعوبه في الاعلان بانهم بيتنافسوا
خاصه
لمحبين او لما تحديد المحبين قال شطرنج
كشفوا معلومه لسه
اكثر واكثر فترتيب حجاره الشطرنج لاحظت
الناس انه نفس ترتيبهم في مباراه شطرنج
شهيره بين ماغنس كارزون وهيكارو هناكمورا
في 2017 واللي بيعتبروا اساطير شطرنج
والمباراه خلصت بالتعادل فكانوا الاعلان
مستخدم رساله التعادل هذه وبيلمح فيها
للتعادل او التساوي بين رونالدو وميسي
والمنافس الازليه حول مين الافضل واللي
الان ما تم حسمها اما الفتاه الاخيره اللي
فعليا ملعوبه فهي في الشنطه اللي بيلعبوا
عليها الشنطه هذه هي الشنطه اللي بينهم
خلفيها كاس العالم نفسه هما حاملين كاس
العالم باختصار الاعلان كانه بيقول انه
الاثنين للان في عالم كره القدم متعادلين
وفاضل الفاصل اللي بين هم واللي بيلعبوا
عليه حاليا وهو كاس العالم هو الحلم اللي
لسه لمس يحققه للارجنتين ولا رونالدو حققه
للبرتغال فعليا فعلا مجنون اللاعبين طبعا
نشروا الصور على حساباتهم مع تعليق واحد
وهو النصر حاله
المصوره الشهيره اللي ملتقطه الصوره وهي
يعني اللبس
رجعوا كمان ونشروا فيديو من كواليس تصوير
الاعلان وهنا كان في مفاجاه ثانيه وهي انه
اللاعبين مكانه حاضرين مع بعض وقت التصوير
كل واحد اتصور لوحده وبعدين بعد ثلاث صوره
ديزني
[موسيقى]
ميركل خريطه
الصوره حديث الناس فعليا في كل مكان وحتى
رونالدو في مؤتمر صحفي على هامش كاس
العالم ان سال عنها ورد كان انه نفسي اكون
اللاعب اللي يقول لي ميسي كش ملك في كره
القدم
يندم الينا رئيس قسم التسويق في جامعه
الفيصل دكتور سعد الحقيل اهلا فيك معانا
دكتور سعاد يعني الناس لما شافت الاعلان
انصدموا لي كثير اسباب بس يمكن واحده من
الاشياء انه الشركه بحجم ماركت الويفيتو
بحاجه انها تعمل اعلان من هذا النوع تستقط
فيه اثنين من اكبر نجوم العالم
بسم الله شكرا على الاستضافه ردا على
سؤالك اول شيء الاعلان يخلق قيمه
اخلاق انطباع ولا انطباع شيء مطلوب ومرغوب
من ناحيه المستهلك
ومن ناحيه الشركه والانطباع لما يخلق قيمه
قيمه مرغوبه وسهل فاهمه لما نتكلم بشكل
عام علميا عن اهميه الاعلام بالنسبه الى
هذا بالعكس اغلب الشركات التي تحتاج فعلا
الاعلام هذا الجمال بهذا التخطيط بهذا
الذكاء بهذا الغموض الذي شركات الموضه ولا
سيما اهمها نجحها على اطلاقه
ان الاعلان والاعلان جدا رائع جدا الاسباب
كثيره خلال هذا اللقاء ولكن شركات الموضه
دائما تحتاج الاعلان لان المنتجات التي
تعتمد كثيرا على التواجد احنا اليوم بشكل
ابسط مستغرب مثلا
بالعالم
وباكلمك والله
فتواجدها في الاماكن المهمه في المناسبات
الكبيره زي كاس العالم مع النجوم والكبار
يعطي القيمه اللي تكلمنا عنها في بدايه
المداخ فالاعلان اذن للشركات الفخمه او
شركات الموضه
اهم منا لاي شركه اخرى لانها تبيع قيمه
منك مش محتاجين بهذا الاعلان انه يقولوا
للناس تعالوا اشتروا اغراضنا هم بيعلنوا
عن قوه البراند نفسه مستمدين انه من الحدث
اللي هو كاس العالم ومن حجم النجوم
الجميله
زاد السلام
دائما الشركات الموضه او الشركات اللي
بتخصصه
لغايه الثمن تحتاج تكون متواجده مع خاص
بقمه النجاح للنجمين هذول يعني نجمين على
مستوى الرياضات كامله يعني اكثر من قرن
وهم دائما على الاعلام
يضيف بس نقطه واحده انا اعتقد انه اعلان
جدا مدروس وفي قاعده افريقيا تقول له
فريده او الراكب المجاني يعني اعتقد لو
فيتون لو راحت سويت سبونسر لكاس العالم
مع استغلت الحدث بشكل عام وكلام الناس
يعني اليوم او من قبل امس تقريبا طفى
نغمات الحرب في الاعلام وصعد يعني نغمه
كاس العالم فتخيل كل شيء يحكي عن رونالدو
وميسي هم افضل او اكثر لاعبين الاعلامي
يدور حولهم تقدر تسوي الترابط هذا بكاس
العالم مع علامه تجاريه انا اعتقد انها
واحد من اعظم الاعلانات يعني انت بتقول
انه كمان هما راحوا استفادوا من الضجه
الاعلاميه اللي صارت يعني كمان
طبعا نسميها في رايد انا اعرف انه حجم
الكفر الاعلاميه على الكره الكبيره اليوم
كم مره يكتبوا ميسي هيطلع على طول محركات
البحث
رونالدو
طيب الاعلان زي ما ذكرنا وحضرتك ذكرت يعني
اعلان ذكي في كثير رسائل موجوده وكل شويه
بتطلع تفاصيل انه حتى
اللعيبه الشطرنج كانوا ماخذين نفس القعده
هذه الطاوله هي نفسها الاماكن
الاحجار الشطرنج وكل داب هذه الرسائل
المبطنه يعني مو كل احد هيفا فهمها هم ليش
مهتمين انهم يحطوها
جميل انا اعتقد الماركات ال ال ال الثمينه
والاعلانات الجيده والافلام حتى الافلام
الكويسه لازم يندرج في سيناء
[موسيقى]
دقيقه
نتكلم عن تفاصيل التفاصيل التفاصيل انت
لما تشتري قمر
فخم جدا تهتم بكل التفاصيل
هذه المطلوبه لانجاح الاعلان السوري او
القصه زي ما اتفضلتي انت سردتيها الان من
كذا انهم قاعدين يلعبون على الشنطه
الرئيسيه لتنقل كاس العالم بمعنى اللي
هيفوز منهم هياخذ الكاس اللي جوه الشنطه
مرتبط بالعلامه التجاريه ارتباط كلي ومفعل
اكبر نجمين همم القصه مربوطه باثر يعني
معروف اللي هي التنافس الكبير همم
يعني كل التفاصيل في متناقمه وكل يوم
اكتشافك اكتشاف الناس اللي اسرار بالكوشي
ايه ممتع صح ان الجلسه كل شويه بتتكشف
بالتفاصيل وجلسين بيبداولاها وزي ما قلت
هذا اصلا كمان بيزيد التغطيه حول هذا
الموضوع نحنا بنشكرك على هذه المعلومات
كان معنا رئيس قسم التسويق في جامعه
الفيصل دكتور سعد الحقيل شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
اما الان في مع نشره اخبار
اليوميه واللي بيتصدرها عنوان طرد
الموظفين من تويتر خاصه بعد تقارير امس
لبنان برجالت انه اليوم الاثنين ماسك راح
يسرح مجموعه جديده من الموظفين وتحديدا من
اقسام المبيعات والشركات لكن الان احنا ما
شفنا اي شيء من هذه الاخبار او انباء عن
اقالات جديده على ارض الواقع لكن اللافت
حقيقه انه وسط هذه الدراما والدوامه
والعاصفه اللي شغاله هذه كلها
على الاخر يعني الرجال جالس في الساعات
الماضي على حسابه عادي ولا على باله بينقط
وبيضحك واخر من استلمهم تريقه وهم شبكه
السي بي اس لانه السي بي اس كانت اعلنت من
كم يوم اذا بتتذكره انه راح توقف نشاطه
على تويتر
بحساباتهم كلها على تويتر استلمهم
ونشر الصوره اللي شايفينها وعنوانها حبنا
اللي ما بيموت وفيها رجال يعني كاتب على
راسه انه بيحضن ماسك او رجع كتب على راسه
سي بي اس تحديدا وبيحضن ماسك وبيقول له
الليمو قادر اتخلى عنك فيعني بيتمسخر يعني
انه مو قادر على فراق او انه سي بي اس مش
قادر على فراق تويتر ماسك كمان نكد على
انه تويتر حاليا في العالم تعليقات على
موضوع كاس العالم ورجعت ترامب وعلى هذا
الموضوع نشر فيديو بيتخيل حاله
اللي مو طبيعي
[موسيقى]
رجعت ترامب على تويتر
ولا حتى لشرح اللي فيها اللي يحب يروح
يشوفها على الحساب ماسك لكن بمناسبه
الحديث عن رجعت ترامب صار عليه اكثر من 87
مليون متابع وترامب قبل الحظر من سنتين
كان حسابه عليه 88 مليون متابع يعني
باختصار في اقل من 48 ساعه جمع تقريبا نفس
عدد المتابعين اللي جمعهم في 11 سنه
يكونوا فتح حسابه للمره الاولى في
2009 واذا خلصنا من اخبار مصر
على تويتر
من شهر ونص تقريبا
حساب كان فجاه وشفنا غرد تست انه يعني
بيختبر الحساب رجع او لا وبعدها بكم ساعه
غره الثاني بكلمه واحده بس عملت جدل كبير
فكتب شلوم اللي معناها سلام بالعبري يعني
واحد متهم بمعاداده الساميه بغرد بالعبري
في اول يوم حسابه يرجع فيه يعني تغريده
غير مفهومه ومقصد غير مفهوم لكن على الاقل
خلينا نقول ان الغموض والغرابه هذه مو
غريب عن شخصيه سكانيا اللي سمعته من
الاسباب او اللي سمعته مو الاسباب حتى هذه
كلها اللي انا جلسات اتكلم عنه الاسباب
الوحيده التي تصدر ثاني الاخبار في
الساعات الماضيه لانه كمان اعلن عن ترشحه
لرئاسه امريكا في 20 24 ف خلال اللقاء
حصري له مع قناه على يوتيوب وطالع معه في
اللقاء شخص اسمه
بوليس قال يعني انه ماله هيكون مدير حملته
ولما نسال هذا اعلان رسمي ردمايلو وقال
نعم للتذكير كان رشح نفسه وترف 2020 ونجح
فيه طرح اسمه رسميا على قناه اوائم
التصويت في اكثر من ولايه لكن ما كمل
المنافسه بعدها
[موسيقى]
الم من جديد في مقطع فيديو منتشر ومتداول
بشكل كبير على تويتر للرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون وعنوانه صفحه جديده
يتلقاها الرئيس الفرنسي
هي بدل ما تقولي
بشكل كبير مثل ما قلت لكم
على الجديد
بس ماخوذه هذه المره من زاويه جديده يعني
واضح جدا انه بين الفيديوهات
وبيتعرض لصفحه من شاب اسمه
الزيتي عموما الصفحه الجديده او قديمه فهي
للاسف مو الاعتداء الاول منه الوحيد اللي
تعرض له مكرون من وقت ما صار رئيس
اه
[موسيقى]
تستعد
في مهرجان القاهره السينمائي بيتكلم عن
القصه البطوليه لاختين من سوريا ساره
الى الشاطئ ولاحقا يسري شاركت في فريق
اللاجئين للسباحه في اولمبياد ريو
[موسيقى]
في تفاعلكم كمان هذا اللقاء مع مخرجات
الفيلم سالي الحسيني انا اترككم
غدا ان شاء الله في امان الله
ولا نسوان
ولكن
كلاش كلاش
هذا بالنسبه
ايكوستاريكاشنكي
ستوري كبيره
[موسيقى]